– Und bald fahren wir
gemeinsam in den Urlaub!
– Und du glaubst,
dass es eine gute Idee ist?
– Ja, wieso denn nicht?
Im Gegensatz zu den meisten
Männern ist Jacques
rücksichtsvoll, charmant,
humorvoll, romantisch …
– Was heißt denn „im Gegensatz
zu den meisten Männern“?
– Na, viele Männer sind unsensibel
und reagieren verständnislos, wenn sie …
hey, hey, hey!
– Es tut mir leid, aber Klischees
werden hier nicht bedient.
– Ihr seid aber heute auch sensibel.
– Hi!
– Hallo, Nico!
– Hi, Nico!
– Warum haben wir deinen Jacques
eigentlich noch nicht gesehen?
Hast du kein Foto von ihm?
– Oder sieht er vielleicht gar nicht
so gut aus, wie du immer sagst?
– Jetzt werd bloß nicht frech!
Jacques ist sehr attraktiv.
Er ist groß und schlank,
er hat schöne Augen und …
Moment! Hier.
– Kann ich das bitte noch mal sehen?
Das ist Otto, der Fahrradhändler von Yara.
– Wie bitte? Ein Fahrradhändler?
So ein Quatsch! Das ist Jacques!
– Ich sag ja nur, dass er so aussieht.
– Wieso red ich überhaupt mit euch?
– Weil du uns magst, liebe Inge!
– Und weil wir immer noch
die besten Köche sind, die du kennst.
– Hm.